If you're a teenager watching this and you
have some symptoms of an entrepreneur, or
you kind of want to become an entrepreneur,
but you don't know yet, I almost feel bad
for you.
Let me tell you why.
Because becoming an entrepreneur is very similar
to becoming an artist.
And most kids who are artists are different.
So academia, our school system is not structured
to really water this artist and turn him into
what they could be.
I can only imagine how weird of a kid Johnny
Depp was to a teacher in 6th grade.
I can only imagine how Picasso was seen in
school or an Einstein was seen in school.
The same with entrepreneurs.
This is why.
99% of your teachers in school are not entrepreneurs.
And they've never been an entrepreneur.
So how do they know to speak your language?
So you are going to feel a little weird.
You are going to feel a little bit different,
and I simply want to create this platform
for you to look at this video and share it
with your other peers to say, one you're not
alone, and two, it's going to be a little
bit weird.
And just bear with it.
It's going to be okay.
14 Common mistakes I'll give you today.
A lot of them I went through myself, and hopefully
it will give you some value for you to be
thinking about.
That the future looks bright and don't overthink
it too much.
So let's get right into it.
Point number one here's point number one.
Life is not Disneyland, the happiest place
on earth.
That is a lie.
That's what you call a commercial.
That's what gets people to want to go to Disneyland
where for one day we're at Disneyland and
we think we're at the happiest place on earth.
That's called creative marketing.
That's called fantastic marketing.
Let me tell you a shocker here for you to
know.
Most of your friends don't want to see you
succeed.
That's confusing.
Most of the people in school don't want to
see you kill it.
Very few do.
I know this is very weird.
It's almost as if your friends are very happy,
as long as you do a little bit less than they
do.
So if you get a B+, they're okay if they got
an A. If you are dating a pretty girl, it's
okay, as long as they're dating a prettier
girl.
But they're not happy if you're doing better
than them.
So you've got to know that part.
And it's nothing wrong.
This doesn't mean your friends are bad people.
It's just how people are wired, for the most
part.
And I know a lot of comments people are going
to say, I don't think that's what it is.
My best friend thinks the world of me, and
she loves me, and he loves me.
You can keep thinking like that, but life's
not Disneyland.
You're going to be shell shocked very early
on, when you go through life.
#2: Don't worry about breaking too many rules.
I'm here to tell you, I think too many teenage
entrepreneurs don't break the rules enough
times.
I didn't say law.
I said rules.
Break the rules.
You've got to break the rules more.
Why?
Because the only way we figure out how to
make anything better is by breaking it down
a little bit and breaking the rules a little
bit to find out if we can do this thing a
little bit better than the way it's been done
all these years.
Don't worry about breaking the rules too often.
People are going to make you feel bad and
all this other stuff, don't worry about it.
Break more rules.
Not laws.
Don't come back and say "Pat told me to break
the law."
I never said law.
Break more rules.
Not laws, but rules.
Number three is comparing yourself too much
with others.
You don't need to compare yourself to other
people.
This person did this, that person did this,
this person did this.
Even a Zuckerberg, even a Musk, or all these
guys, let them inspire you, but don't compare
yourself to other people.
Here's why.
There's no way in the world you can be like
them.
And there's no way in the world they can be
like you.
Very simple.
You're unique.
They're unique.
Play to your own unique abilities.
You don't need to worry about comparing yourself
to everybody else.
Next point.
Being too concerned as a young entrepreneur
about somebody else stealing your ideas.
Listen.
Don't worry if someone's going to steal your
ideas.
First of all, you hoarding your idea is not
going to tell the world anything anyways.
The biggest challenge you got to know about
ideas is that 99.99% of the world is going
to do nothing with your idea.
Just know this.
99.999% of the people are not going to take
your idea at all.
They're just not going to take it.
Because the entire game is execution.
So I would much rather be a little bit more
comfortable about sharing your idea with other
people than saying, "I'm not going to tell
anybody."
If you keep it, the world's definitely not
going to know about it.
If you talk to somebody else, they can possibly
help you turn that idea into a bigger idea
than it currently is today.
Next, this is very powerful.
Pay very close attention to what I'm telling
you right now.
Don't let logic bully you.
Let me say it again.
What is logic?
Age, age bullies people.
Let me elaborate.
There will be a 42-year-old teacher that you
have.
And you're this 14-year-old kid.
And you've got dreams.
And you say, "One day I'm going to be this,
and one day I'm going to be this, and one
day I'm going to be this."
And you get the smirk from that teacher that
say, "Oh, I remember when I was your age and
I used to dream that life was going to be
this, but it's not!"
That's a logical thinker.
They gave up at one point.
Do not let that logical person influence you.
Don't.
You keep dreaming.
I know the word "logic-er" is not a word because
the dreamer vs. a logic-er, logic-er is not
a word, I'm making it a word.
Don't let a person that purely looks at everything
through the logical views bully a dreamer,
which is you.
Don't let them do it.
Do not let them do it.
And a lot of times it's age.
It's a 52-year-old uncle who thinks he knows
everything but he's broke!
His report card is a straight F. Stop taking
that uncle's advice.
He got an F. The only advice you need to take
from that uncle is the following advice.
What mistakes did you make to get you to where
you're at right now?
If you truly want to help me out, Mr. Uncle,
it's tell me about the mistakes on why you're
still broke, living in an apartment complex.
Tell me the mistakes.
Don't bully my dreams.
I have dreams.
And I want to give a shot to see if I can
go out there and make my dreams become a reality.
You gave up.
You screwed up.
Tell me your mistakes.
I'm willing to listen to you with your mistakes.
But I don't want you to bully my dreams.
If you want to bully my dreams, I don't even
want to hear it.
I don't want to hear any of it.
So don't let age or logic bully you.
Next, team up with the most driven in school,
not your best friends.
A lot of times your best friends are your
best friends and you like them, but one of
them is more concerned about smoking pot and
having sex with his girlfriend 24/7 than doing
anything big with his life.
You can't do anything with that guy, because
he doesn't want to work.
Some of your friends are more worried about
the cool points they're going to get and all
this other stuff.
But then there's that one cat who's a nerd,
and nobody talks to him, but he's a ridiculous
coder.
You go make friends with him.
There's another guy that works 24/7.
He sells baseball cards on campus, and he's
always selling something, and everyone makes
fun of him - befriend that guy.
Because that guy can help you sell your product.
he can be your Steve Jobs.
Go find somebody, the hardest working people
on campus that are selling that are running
businesses, making money on the side, hustling
on Instagram, doing stuff on Snapchat.
Befriend them.
Get them together, not just your best friends.
Completely different strategy you got to take
with that.
Next, this sounds like a preachy type of thing,
but listen, take care of your health early.
Avoid Burger King, McDonald's, all that fast
food stuff.
It's just not necessary for you to eat that
stuff.
Some of you guys wonder why you get a lot
of acne.
It's just eating a lot of oily food.
You don't need to eat the oily food.
I used to have acne a lot as a kid.
Oily food is not the way to go.
Avoid that stuff.
Take care of your health, very, very early.
The moment I figured out the whole oily thing,
I started working out and taking care of my
health, somewhat earlier, more than some of
my peers did.
It benefited me.
Start taking care of your health earlier.
Next, reading crappy books.
You don't need to read crappy books.
Now let me tell you what I don't mind, when
I say crappy books.
If you read books that are about imagination
and it takes you to some places that makes
you visualize things that are just crazy,
that's fine.
That's cool to be reading books like that.
I'm talking about books that have no purpose,
that serve no purpose to you.
Read business books.
I'm going to make another video on top 10
books teenage entrepreneurs need to read,
but that will be another episode that comes
up.
Stay tuned for that.
But for now, just avoid reading crappy books.
Next one.
Learn the difference between ass kissing and
networking - there's a big difference.
Some students want to kiss ass to their teachers.
Right?
We used to call them TA or teacher's pet and
all this other things that they say.
Don't be an ass kisser.
Be a great networker.
Let me tell you who to network with.
Here's a perfect thing to be thinking about.
Go to your principal, ask around, which one
of the teachers in your school at one point
was a professional athlete.
Go ask them what it takes to be a professional
athlete.
Two, find out any teacher, principal, counselor,
on campus who used to run a successful business
before, who sold it.
Now their way of giving back to public is
they want to become teachers.
Befriend that teacher.
Take that teacher out to lunch.
Take that teacher out and say, when can you
spend an hour with me after school?
Go network with that person.
By the way, you can find out who those teachers
are.
In every school you go to, I promise you right
now if you're watching this, if I were to
ask you, who's the richest teacher on campus?
I guarantee you, everybody typically knows
who's the richest teacher on campus.
Everyone knows it.
You know why?
Because everybody talks about it.
And by the way, FYI, the majority of the teachers
don't like that teacher.
Because that teacher has money, and they did
it backwards.
They first went and made their money, then
they became teachers.
A lot of these teachers became teachers right
after school and some of them aren't doing
too well money wise, because they don't make
a lot of money.
I admire teachers.
Don't get me wrong.
Teachers impacted my life tremendously.
But if you want to network, network with the
guy that knows all the right people.
Next, stop trying to be cool.
When you're young, I was dying to be cool
when I was 12, 13, 14 years old.
You know, I had just come to America.
I had a terrible accent.
I didn't even know how to pronounce certain
words.
You're going to spend way too much time trying
to be cool, and trying to make everybody else
happy.
Don't fall for it.
Just realize, this is you, this is how you
are, maximize what you got, don't try to get
cool points from everybody else.
Next point.
avoid putting yourself in dumb situations.
Let me just simplify it for you.
This is not something that's complicated.
I remember a few occasions in my life.
Once I got arrested in Hollywood at 1:00 in
the morning, I got arrested.
Cops came, handcuffed, the whole nine.
It could have been worse, but it didn't.
We were good, we left.
Everything was fine.
We didn't get arrested or anything that night.
But they handcuffed use.
Helicopters chasing us, all this other stuff.
I was 16 years old.
I had just bought a new car.
Another one was a big fight that took place
and I was hanging out with the peers.
And this fight was a very big fight.
Cops came, they were about to arrest me, and
the other guys that were with us.
I was about to get arrested.
There were a few people that night that got
felonies.
And I was able to, after conversations with
the cops, they were able to let me go.
Let me tell you why this is so critical for
you to pay attention to.
If I would have gotten that felony at a young
age, let's just say if that would have happened,
I would have never gone into the Army.
If I would have never gone into the Army for
three years, I wouldn't have learned the discipline.
If I wouldn't have gone and learned the discipline
in the Army and gotten out, and wanted to
be this body builder, I would have never met
a girl named Jarnvier.
If I would have never met a girl named Jarnvier,
I would have never worked at Morgan Stanley
Dean Witter.
And if I would have got a misdemeanor or a
felony, Morgan Stanley Dean Witter would have
never hired me.
You know why?
Because you can't go into the securities industry
with a felony, for 10 years.
So I would have never gone into the financial
industry.
This entire story of PBD is a different story.
This entire story of Patrick Bet-David, Valuetainment,
PHP, is a complete different story.
So don't put yourself in dumb situations.
What are some of the dumb situations?
Condoms.
Drugs.
Pot.
Alcohol.
DUI.
Pregnancy.
Avoid some of those situations because they
can be a major setback to a lot of people.
Next one here.
Don't make sex your god.
I know when you're thirteen years old, you're
fourteen years old, boys especially, all you
think about is sex, sex, sex, will I ever
have sex.
Let me make a prediction to you.
The chances of you having sex is very high.
And not only sex.
You're going to have a lot of sex in your
life.
Lots of it.
I promise you.
No one is 42 years old, sitting there saying,
oh my gosh, I didn't have enough.
. . you're going to be fine.
The more attention you give to that, the more
your mind is going to places instead of trying
to come up with ideas and all these other
thoughts.
Your mind is being consumed by thoughts that
really are not going to do anything for you.
And by the way, I understand the hormonal
thing, and at that age, wind breezes this
way, you're excited.
You see somebody every other day we fall in
love with somebody new.
One day its Vivica Fox, one day it's Rachel
McAdams, another day it's Jennifer this, another
day it's Jessica Biel, another day it's this.
Don't worry.
You're going to get plenty of this, plenty
of this.
Just don't make sex your god.
Just trust me on this.
You'll find out what I mean ten years from
now.
Just trust me on this.
Okay, next one.
The next one is, feeling like you don't matter.
Let me explain.
Sometimes, depending on the family you're
raised in, you may be raised in a family where
your parents are going through a divorce,
or there's a lot of hate, screaming, shouting,
fighting, arguing.
And there are a lot of things that your mom
and dad are going through, that you will never
know about.
Let me tell you that.
So sometimes, parents, no one's perfect, a
mom, or a dad, is going to put out their frustration
on their kids.
It's just kind of what happens.
Because you're around the most, especially
if you're raised around a divorced family.
Sometimes they're going to put their anger,
their frustration, their regrets, their own
stuff.
They don't mean it.
You just happen to be there.
They say those types of things, to you, and
these things become scars.
Scars.
And the biggest challenge with this is, is
if you start believing it.
You've got to be, I mean, you've got common
sense, because anything after six, seven,
eight years old, you start developing some
common sense.
You got common sense to know that they don't
really fully mean it.
They're in pain.
They're in a lot of pain.
This doesn't mean it's not going to hurt.
This doesn't mean it's not going to stick.
This doesn't mean you're going to forget about
it.
But it doesn't mean it's the truth.
So if they say some words to you, like you'll
never amount to anything, you'll never do
this, you'll never do that, to me, that can
actually toughen you up, for you to say, you
know what, this is my opportunity to prove
that I can be somebody, and not only that,
for you to really dig in, dig deep, and realize
that everybody else out there, like imagine,
the kid who invented Cannon.
At one point he was eight years old, with
a dream.
What if he gave up?
Imagine Steve Jobs, when he was 10 years old,
and his mom gave him up for adoption for somebody
else, when he was a young kid.
Now what if this kid gives up on Apple.
Imagine if Wozniak who was a kid, a geek one
time, playing the video games and breaking
down every single thing that he had and putting
them back, what if he gave up, because somebody
told him something.
What if Zuckerberg gave up?
What if Musk gave up?
What if Travis gave up?
What if all these guys gave up?
All these guys were kids at one point.
Barack Obama was a former president we had.
At one point he was six years old and a kid
that people laughed at.
Donald Trump's the current president.
At one point he was 10 years old and people
laughed at him.
So, the same way they go through it, the same
way you got to realize is that one day you're
going to be 52 years old, and you have the
ability to impact everybody around the world,
don't let some of those words that people
in pain impact you of your decision to go
out there and do something big with your life.
Stay patient.
Good things are going to be around the corner
for you.
Don't buy into their challenges that they're
facing.
And last but not least, the one I'll give
you here, last but not least is studying the
right content.
Let me tell you what I mean by studying the
There's a lot of people on the Internet right
now, telling you what to do and what not to
do.
And you'll have to learn how to decipher between
the right content and the wrong content.
But I'm here to tell you this.
I suggest you go backwards and go through
every single Valuetainment Episode that we
have on YouTube.
Right now one of the things that's happening
is Valuetainment has become a phenomenon among
teenage entrepreneurs.
Obviously, CEOs of multi-multi-billion dollar
companies are following Valuetainment.
The CEO of Sprint the other day retweeted
one of the episodes that we had.
We're getting celebrities now that are following
us.
We're getting billionaires that are now following
this.
But there's also a very big following of teenage
entrepreneurs on Valuetainment.
I wish, when I was 13 years old there was
a channel like Valuetainment for me to watch
the episodes.
Study the right content.
There's a lot of good content out there as
well.
But study the right content, based on people
who are running businesses.
Not based on people who are telling you things
that they picked up from a book.
Always find out how the person that's teaching
you the content online has made their money.
This is what I call a trifecta entrepreneur,
somebody that has theories, somebody that
has experience, and somebody that's applying
their theories and their experience and they're
winning now in the world of entrepreneurship.
So make sure you're getting that content.
So my challenge to you would be, watch the
Valuetainment content.
Go back to back to back with these episodes.
And you'll be amazed, in two weeks, three
weeks, four weeks, we get hundreds of messages
from teenage entrepreneurs from around the
world that say, last month I made $16,000,
this month I made $8,000, this week I made
$4,000, last month I made $28,000.
I had a 17-year-old kid that came to Houston
to visit me.
He's still in high school.
He made $57,000 last month as a teenage entrepreneur.
And if you would have seen him, he's an innocent
- you would have never thought he made $57K
at 17 years old, but he did.
So study the content, follow the content,
comment on the bottom, and if you got some
questions, you can always snap me, the snap
tab should be right here, betdavid19.
I will generally respond.
We're getting thousands of messages now, so
if I don't get back to you, send it again.
We'll eventually get back to you.
So, with that being said, we'll get our new
pillow here, Paul, that was not the best throw,
but we'll forgive you.
And it's football season, man.
Why would you throw it like the way they shot
free throws back in the day.
Hey, if you got questions, comment on the
bottom.
If you haven't subscribed to this channel,
click on the subscribe button here and notification
to be the first to be notified every time
new videos come up.
Our goal is to get to a million subs by the
end of the year.
We need your help to help us get to a million
subs by the end of 2017.
With that being said, thanks so much for watching
everybody.
Take care, bye bye.